le constructeur automobile volkswagen
dans la tourmente
quatre ans après le début du scandale
les consommateurs exigent des indemnités
pour rappel en septembre 2015 le
constructeur allemand reconnaît avoir
vendu aux états unis près de 500 mille
voitures équipées de moteurs truqués
dans le but de dissimuler les émissions
polluantes de leur véhicule en réalité
près de 11 millions étaient concernés un
scandale pour la dèche qualité dont les
mérites sont souvent vanté les marques
concernées sont audi skoda seat et
volkswagen pour faire tomber le premier
constructeur mondial de véhicules dans
le monde
les consommateurs ont décidé de se
rassembler la fondation néerlandaise
diesel émission justice lance une action
groupée en france elle appelle toute
personne qui s'estime victime de la
duperie à renseigner son état civil via
un site dédié
objectif donner mandat à l'association
pour le représenter volkswagen doit
enfin admettre qu'ils ont menti et ne
pas toujours se contenter de parler du
problème du diesel mais mentir et
tricher ce n'est pas seulement un
problème c'est bien pire qu'un problème
si en europe les pignons n'ont pour le
moment pas reçu un centime dans
plusieurs pays du monde
volkswagen a dû payer de lourds
dédommagements aux états unis près de 25
milliards d'euros 80 millions d'euros
pour l'australie et au canada 135
millions ont été versés par la firme au
motif de violation des lois de
l'environnement une industrie allemande
à l'époque exemplaires aujourd'hui
ternie ce scandale a contribué au déclin
du diesel et à favoriser l'attrait pour
l'électrique mais un scandale sanitaire
les particules fines émises par les
moteurs diesel génère des problèmes
respiratoires et cardiovasculaires
important pour l'homme et pour fabrice
godefroy président de l'association
dédiée des listes de france cette
affaire a eu beaucoup de conséquences
sur la filière écoutez le c'est une
démarche qui votent à mon avis est
extrêmement longue
par contre il faut que les consommateurs
prennent aussi en compte que
effectivement peut-être qu'ils vont
avoir des indemnités par rapport à ça
mais par contre derrière cette affaire
du diesel gate est une problématique
pour eux derrière parce que derrière
qu'est-ce qu'on a eu on a eu les
augmentations des prix des carburants
sous sous cette forme là en se servant
en fait de cet argument là on a les
restrictions et les zones de faibles
émissions alors qu'ils ne touchent pas
que le diesel parce que souvent on dit
on va interdire le diesel en 2024 mais
il faut quand même pas oublier qu'à
paris par exemple madame hidalgo annoncé
qu'en 2030 ce sera aussi la fin du
moteur thermique thermique ça veut dire
quoi
diesel essence hybride donc c'est très
important
donc faut faire attention parce que dans
ce genre de démarche qui est finalement
issu d'une triche d'un constructeur ça a
touché l'ensemble d'une filière
et comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça a
touché aussi tous les consommateurs et a
des répercussions extrêmement importante
il faut faire bien attention parce que
quand on fait par exemple une
restriction automobile de véhicules qui
ne pourront plus roulé qui ont été
achetés alors que la carte grise
jusqu'à preuve du contraire n'avait pas
une date de péremption ça veut dire
qu'on est en train de créer une
obsolescence programmée sur les
véhicules
donc tout ça c'est des répercussions qui
sont quand même très important il faut
faire très attention